with my friend Justin I'm at his house
right now Kristin Cavallari who
announced her split with Jay Cutler last
month reveals she's been staying with
her best friend we've been together the
entire quarantine time literally from
day one on Saturday the reality star was
on Instagram live with her stylist and
she opened up about mom life to Jay
actually has always here so there's the
33 year old gets real about
homeschooling her three kids and admits
it's been a struggle I also you like the
no school thing is tough college Jackson
will not listen to me and he refuses to
do work and I'm like I can't fight with
you over dudes for work
it's too hard I mean my kids are young
so that's nice my boys are seven and six
so it's not the end of the world if
they're not sitting here doing
schoolwork every day but they're just
you know everyone's getting like a
little stir-crazy because we can't
really go anywhere another big
adjustment basically her entire schedule
I used to wake up at 5:00 a.m. every
morning work out and then I would get my
kids ready for school take them to
school and then go to the office and
it's like I haven't set an alarm since
all this is going on I'm like she's even
given in to her kids hopping in bed with
her because of my kids I get up between
anywhere between like 6:30 and 8:00 and
I don't normally let my kids sleep with
me but I have been rotating my kid for
the last week Wow
but even with all the big changes
Kristen is trying to really enjoy the
quality time she spends with her littles
that's cute like those are the moments
but it'll never be the same like we'll
never get those back you know so in that
sense I'm just trying to like really
enjoy that time with my kids
Kristin's divorce from Jay has been an
adjustment to their split was at first
amicable but things took a turn a source
told et that Jay was upset over Kristin
requesting primary physical custody of
their kids my kids my family they're my
number one priority they always will be
in the court documents obtained by et
Kristen a
used J of marital misconduct in her
divorce filing from outside like things
are so perfect and things are so great
but actually like they're not and that's
so she's also claimed the former NFL
star was trying to control their marital
assets and was preventing her from
buying her own home it's been
interesting we've really completely
shifted roles so it's just been trying
to like navigate this new normal but the
two were able to reach a permanent
parenting plan earlier this month and
Kristen was able to buy a new home in
Franklin Tennessee you know we make do
we figure it out and seems like they
have J shared and Instagram posts
honoring Kristen on Mother's Day last
week
[Music]